human rights activists are urging Iran
to stop executing protesters authorities
have carried out a number of death
sentences since the demonstrations
against the regime began more than three
months ago one of those currently
waiting to be executed is Gara asan Lu
for allegedly being involved in the
death of a member of the security forces
his wife was also arrested and tortured
before being given a lengthy prison
sentence DW has been speaking with
Hassan Lou's brother who lives in the
Netherlands
Hamid and fatsana Gara Hassan Lu a
married couple with a very Bleak future
I saw photos of them in court I was so
shocked
it looked like they had aged by a decade
or two in just three weeks
[Music]
was sentenced to death
his wife fatzana to 25 years
imprisonment
[Music]
the couple attended a ceremony at the
start of November to honor Hadith najafi
after her death
twenty-year-old Hadith was shot during a
protest
in the night after the ceremony the
couple were beaten and arrested in front
of their two children by Iran's
voluntary militia the bazige they were
accused of participating in the death of
the member of the bazish militia during
a protest
Gary's brother who lives in the
Netherlands says his life has turned
into a nightmare
[Applause]
the last time my brother called me I
couldn't take his call
I had planned to call him back the next
day but I didn't know
I can't forgive myself now
[Music]
says no evidence was presented in the
trial of his brother and sister-in-law
he added that there was no proof for the
accusation that his brother kicked the
killed member of the militia
the only evidence for the death sentence
was fatsana's coerced confessions under
severe physical and mental torture
confessions that farzana even denied in
court
hamid's brother has x-rays showing the
physical abuse his brother was subjected
to
several ribs were broken from the
torture and the fractures caused his
left lung to bleed foreign
and he had to go to court in that state
he went straight from hospital to court
yes because of the torture he had to
undergo three operations he had barely
recovered from the last one when he was
brought back to the court despite the
severe torture Hamid never confessed to
the murder
when we were kids our biggest dream was
to wake up and see a lot of snow on the
ground that would have been the best
thing for us now I get up every day
hoping or dreaming to see a meter of
snow and fatsana and Javid free I looked
straight to my phone first thing in the
morning for news good news
I start my day with that hope
so we're hearing that from the brother
of an Iranian man who was in danger of
being executed speaking to us here at DW
and we've just heard that that death
sentence has now been lifted let's
consider this with the Mahmoud Amiri
mogadam who's an Iranian human rights
Defender and director of the
norway-based non-governmental
organization Iran human rights welcome
to DW
um you must be very pleased to hear this
news
thank you for having me here well uh yes
so this morning several Iranian
newspapers reported about uh lifting of
this or removal of the death sentence
although they say it's possibly removed
um at the order of a higher official and
the higher official normally who has the
authority to do that is
either the supreme leader or head of the
Judiciary himself but the family hasn't
you know received any official notice
yet so we are not sure but if that's the
case of course we are very happy but we
also know that they are a dozen others
uh waiting or at risk of being executed
and and of course
the international attention around the
case makes it more difficult for the
authorities to actually conduct
executions and do you think that that
that obviously was speculating at this
at this point but do you think that is
that might be part of the reason why
this um execution has been lifted the
international attention that this case
has attracted
absolutely because you know the aim of
the executions is to spread fear the
Iranian authorities they have decided to
do some executions of protesters because
they have realized that after three
months of shooting at them on the
streets killing several hundred of them
there is protests continues so they have
escalated this violence by issuing death
sentences and and we know that the death
penalty is the most uh probably powerful
tool to spread fear
um so at the same time they want to pay
as little price as possible for these
executions so cases that are not known
they are in more danger and it's not a
coincidence that the first protester who
was executed most in shikari basically
there were no pictures of him outside we
did not know so much about him
the the thinking behind the the regime
because the world is seeing these uh
protests clearly the regime is trying to
crack down on them but rather than
charging them with uh Riot they the
charges seems vague things like enmity
against God or corruption on Earth why
not charge them say we are putting you
to death because you took part in these
riots and the rest of you pay attention
to this
well you see it
the vague charges of corruption on Earth
or Mojave Waging War against God
it gives the power to the judges to
basically decide and Define who they
want to sentence to that you know we are
not talking about a rule of law or due
process right these revolutionary courts
they are just extension of these
oppressive organs that you see on the
streets so so basically
I was gonna say thank you they just used
it
for talking to uh DW this morning and we
wish you well with your efforts
from Iran human rights